well while the debate was happening last
night a debate that excluded Mike
Bloomberg Bloomberg was spending his
billions of dollars coming up with a
brilliant marketing campaign that would
outshine what any debate could could put
forward I mean this guy's worth fifty
eight billion dollars fifty eight
billion dollars do you think he needs a
stinking debate to get attention no no
not at all so last night during the
debate
Bloomberg unveiled his brilliant
strategy the strategy that only a man
with fifty eight billion dollars to
spend it could possibly devise or afford
and here it is this is the tweet that he
sent out that was sent out by his
campaign during the debate
it says test your knowledge spot the
meatball that looks like Mike
a bunch of meatballs and one has his
face and printed on it
um wait so this this this you're
comparing yourself to a meatball you you
you are comparing yourself to a meatball
that's the plan
marketing plan that fifty eight billion
dollars comes up with compare yourself
to a meatball
I mean how I'm trying I just I I'm
trying to imagine how this conversation
what there had to have been a
conversation and so it must have been
something like you know Bloomberg comes
at okay folks I'm very rich if you
didn't know I want the best possible PR
strategy I need a killer plan something
revolutionary and someone raises their
hand well mr. Bloomberg you know we
could yes yes Johnson what is it what's
your plan well we we could we could
compare you to a meatball meatball use
yes yeah meatball like with spaghetti we
could you know it's we could point out
that you look like a clumpy lumpy clump
of ground beef because that's the case
we want to put forward to the voters
genius somebody buy this man a Ferrari I
just and you know what's unfortunate
about this
that picture and you're like well you
know what he actually does look like a
meatball I never noticed that before but
now I do so now every time I see Mike
Bloomberg I'm gonna think about
meatballs I don't know if that's really
the the Association he wants us to make
but oh well what are you gonna do I tell
you one thing if if Trump if Donald
Trump and I'm serious about this if
Donald Trump does not nickname Mike
Bloomberg meatball after this then he
should be impeached on that basis alone
mic the meatball meatball mic or just
meatball any of those the possibilities
are endless
I've been saying for a couple years now
it's concerned me I think Trump's
nickname game has slipped considerably
since the 2016 election now's a chance
to reclaim it meatball you got to go
with it
Trump okay as for the debate itself it
was easily the least entertaining debate
yet and that's saying something of
course because the bar for entertainment
with these debates is very very low I
think part of the problem is that CNN
kicked out every candidate who might
have something different something
interesting to say anyone who might stir
things up a little bit they kicked out
and all we got were the boring talking
points viewers like the most boring
people in the in the field are the only
ones left at this point no yang no
Gabbard interestingly enough the only
candidates invited on the stage were
white sure it's just a coincidence right
I mean that stage was whiter than a than
a wine and cheese festival looked like
it looked like a Tupperware party up
there with all the whiteness now I mean
I guess we have to conclude that CNN is
racist that's that's that those are the
rules right those are their rules
so I you know it's not my rules I'm just
saying we have no choice according to
CNN's rules according to liberal rules
CNN is racist the DNC is racist along
with being racist CNN is also
unabashedly in the tank for certain
candidates against others and that came
out last night especially when the
discussion turned to this dispute
between Warren and Sanders about whether
Sanders said in a private meeting
between himself and Warren that a woman
can't win the presidency he was asked
about this a comment by the way that I
don't believe he made but even if he did
who cares it's not sexist okay so it
doesn't even matter this whole this
whole this whole dispute is completely
ridiculous who cares if he said it means
nothing
but I don't think he did he was asked
about this he denied it he pointed out
that he's always said going back 30
years he's always said publicly that he
thinks a woman could win the presidency
he also pointed out that Hillary Clinton
ran for president 2016 got three million
more popular votes than Donald Trump
which obviously proves that the American
people are willing to vote for a woman
not only a woman but they're willing to
vote for the worst woman in America so
only imagine what they would be willing
to do if it was a slightly better woman
than that so his denial is perfectly
plausible and believable well he didn't
say the thing about Hillary Clinton
being the worst woman in America that's
me I'm editor realizing a little bit and
you you know if you're watching the
debate you maybe were expecting if you
were watching the debate under the
delusion that CNN is a legitimate news
operation then you probably were
expecting that after Sanders said no I
didn't say that CNN would turn to Warren
and ask her directly if he did say that
and then ask her to justify or explain
that claim right that's what you would
expect if if CNN is a is a real news out
outfit you that's what you would expect
but that's not what happened here's what
happened instead
I do want to be clear here you're saying
that you never told senator Warren that
a woman could not win the election that
is correct senator Warren what did you
think when senator Sanders told you a
woman could not win the election I
disagreed bernie is my friend and I am
NOT here to try to fight with Bernie but
look this question about whether or not
a woman can be president has been raised
in it's time for us to attack it head-on
and I think the best way to talk about
who can win is by looking at people's
winning record
so can a woman beat Donald Trump look at
the men on this stage collectively they
have lost 10 elections the only people
on this stage who have won every single
election that they've been in are the
women Amy
holy Wow that
so to review what happened here the
moderator asked Bernie about this thing
he supposedly said he denied it
strenuously then the moderator blatantly
dismissed everything he just said
directly contradicted him openly took
war inside and asked her about it on the
assumption that it actually happened
thus saving her from having to actually
directly address the claim or justify it
so she the moderator contradicted Bernie
dismissed it and then bailed Warren out
amazing I mean it's not amazing it's
it's it's not amazing that CNN would act
with such partisanship and with such a
lack of integrity what is maybe a little
bit surprising is that they'd be so
unabashed about it they'd be so open
about it after after the debate
hashtag CNN is trash was trending and it
wasn't because of Trump fans it was it
was these even liberals are starting to
catch on now
I have more to say about this warning
Sanders thing but I don't want to skip
over or forget the comic relief of the
night and this is the part that I think
I said it was not entertaining this was
the only entertaining part of the entire
night and and maybe maybe the most
awkward moment I've ever seen at a
debate I can't think of a more awkward
moment than this and this even includes
all of the GOP primary debates in 2016
and 2015 all the debates including Jeb
Bush who's just he's just the
personification of awkward even more
awkward than that even more awkward than
the the famous fight between Trump and
Marco Rubio about the size of trumps
situation even more awkward than that
was this this is like something straight
out of the office or something it's it's
a comically comically awkward watch this
to set the record straight I defeated an
incumbent Republican running for
Congress
when 1990 that's how I won beat a
Republican congressman number two
there's any debate I beat an incumbent
Republican it's congressman and I said I
was the only one who's beaten an
incumbent Republican in 30 years
well thirty years ago as 1990 as a
matter of fact but I don't know that
that's the major issue of the day that
is brutal
just the awkward pause there everything
this really have has vibes of being at a
dinner table with a married couple when
their marriage is kind of on the rocks
and they're contradicting each other at
every turn and having these these
awkwardly hostile interactions and
you're just sitting there like and
trying desperately to change the subject
I thought that's what it reminded me of
but before we change the subject from
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren one
other thing about this this this he-said
she-said between Warren and Sanders
Warren's
supporters are perhaps not surprisingly
utilizing me to rhetoric to defender
me too is supposed to be allegedly about
sexual assault
there they're going in that direction
with this
they have actually defended her on the
basis of the believe women slogan
remember believed women was the thing
that they said during the me2 movement
we should believe women when they accuse
someone of sexual assault or harassment
while warrants supporters are using that
now in this case against Bernie Sanders
who is not being accused of anything
approaching sexual assault
he's being accused of at most making a
slightly rude comment to Elizabeth
Warren which actually don't think is
rude at all
so just a few examples here Julia loth a
correspondent for GQ apparently wrote
last night still thinking about the
Warren Bernie squabble and I have a
question to people who have accused
Warren of lying isn't the lesson of me
to and the last few years that we
believe women and don't call them liars
other variations on this theme from
Neera Tandon a the president of Center
for American Progress
she says believe women unless it doesn't
work for your ambition apparently from
the always insane Amanda Marcotte she
says I think that Warren got the better
of Sanders in that exchange but who
knows how it will play out I also
thought that eight women accusing Al
Franken of groping was rock solid
evidence that he's a groper but
apparently a lot of people prefer to
believe that women love lying from
Jessica Ellis who's an actor or
something like that I think said just
FYI I double-checked and there is no
except with Elizabeth Warren clause in
that whole believe women deal
from Natalie Monta lon Monta lungo
former Obama staffer
Elizabeth Warren is fire right now
quickly confirming what she what was
said in the private conversation and
pivoting the pointing out that only the
women on the stage have won all their
races but all I gotta say is believe
women
uh Maura Donegan a self-proclaimed angry
feminist writer for The Guardian said I
just wrote a book laying out point by
point how women are denied and demonized
when they come forward with a sexual
assault allegation so watching Warren be
disbelieved and blamed using the same
tactics after saying men set a man said
something sexist to err is pretty
surreal
okay so you get the idea
happening
with believe women
from believe women because they wouldn't
lie about sexual assault pacifically to
believe women because they wouldn't lie
about anything
it went from women are always credible
on this one subject of sexual assault to
women are morally flawless Saints who
are above reproach on all subjects
so now when you accuse a woman of lying
about anything you've got wackos like a
manor Marcotte sang oh so you think
women just love lying huh
think about how dumb and crazy that
would sound if you tried it with any
other demographic imagine if if I don't
know I I was in a parking lot and I hit
somebody's car with my card I tried to
drive away and then they come running
out they say hey hey Jesus hit my car
and then I respond with oh so you think
you think Catholics just love hitting
cars huh
well I didn't hit it but I saw you hit
it oh oh so now you think that Catholics
are all a bunch of liars huh
by the way I'm I'm 6 I'm 6 foot tall
what does that to do with anything well
because now you think that all tall
people are a bunch of liars
of course it sounds just as dumb and
crazy when you apply it to women when
when you try to make a statement of
skepticism about one woman's claim about
one thing into a sexist attack on all
women everywhere
it's this is the dumbest kind of
emotional blackmail
but it works I mean it works on a lot of
people
a lot of people can be successfully
shouted down this way
or they timidly will suggest that oh you
know I don't know if I believe her about
this oh so you think women are liars no
no no no no no no no no yeah she's
probably right she probably did say
but here's the point the progression
from believe women about sexual assault
to believe women about everything was
totally inevitable
because if we're going to accept that
somehow for some unknown reason women
never lie about sexual assault if we're
going to accept that there is any
subject where women are always honest
then why not every subject right because
on whatever basis by whatever
justification we argue for the 100%
credibility of all women on this
particular subject that same argument
could apply to any other subject so
these uh warrant supporters are really
just extending the argument in a logical
way the problem is that the argument
itself is the height of a logic doesn't
make any sense whatsoever
do I think that women can lie yes of
course I do because women are human
beings
when beings are flawed
I think women are just as likely to lie
as men
it's it's it's really it's it could go
either way
and in this in this particular case you
know when you know something about the
people and you can look at their track
record well then you can make hopefully
even more accurate judgments and in this
case with Elizabeth Warren we know that
she's a liar we have documented evidence
of her life
so that's going to weigh against her
here
and yeah you know I'm not even to get
into the fact that once again as I
always point out you can't even do this
anymore this whole thing about women
these these blanket statements about
women you can't do this anymore because
you don't know what a woman is and a
woman doesn't mean anything the whole
term means nothing anymore
men give me women when whoo women can be
men so I got to throw that in as well
it's just just one more layer of
nonsense to all of this
before we move on let's check in with
stamps.com you know time is precious and
you don't need to waste it at the post
office think about all the stuff you
could be doing if you weren't at the
post office wasting your time you could
be you could be you could learn a new
language you could start building model
ships you could I mean I could learn how
to play that banjo that's been hanging
in my office for years so stop wasting
time going to the post office and use
stamps comm instead with stamps comm you
could do anything that you're able to do
at the post office right from your
computer plus stamps comm gives you
something you can't get at the post
office which is big discounts on postage
stamps Tom brings all the surfaces of
use of the US Postal Service right to
your computer whether you're a small
office sending out invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or you're a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day whatever it is stamps comm can
handle all of it with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready just
hand it to your mail carrier or drop it
in the mailbox and it's as simple as
that with stamps comm you get five cents
off every first-class stamp and up to
40% off Priority Mail so give yourself a
resolution that you can actually keep
this year and because it's an easy one
just make things easier on yourself your
your new your your new year's resolution
should be convenience I mean that should
be an easy one to keep stop going to the
post office and go to stamps comm
instead there's no risk and with my
promo code Walsh you get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no long
term commitments or contracts just go to
stamps com look on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in Walsh at
stamps comm promo code Walsh stamps comm
never go to the post office again
so a man in Kansas is in the middle of a
divorce with his wife and he's made an
interesting suggestion he's requested
from the judge that he be allowed to
settle the divorce with swords
trial by combat is what they used to
call it back in the day he's requesting
that the court battle turned into a
battle with Japanese swords though he
will allow his wife to use a stand-in so
it could be his/her attorney or somewhat
someone else
I can imagine if you're going through a
divorce the possibility of being able to
get into a you know duel with swords
with your wife's attorney probably
probably rather rather a fun thing to
think about but anyway very gentlemanly
of him I have to say that he's allowing
his wife to use a stand and and we'll
see how this shakes out but dueling is
technically legal in in many US states
it hasn't been officially abolished or
prohibited and I have always Savi I've
been saying for years that I unyk lis
support dueling I think it's a always
have I think that I think we should
bring it back I think it would make for
a much kinder more polite society in
fact we were just talking yesterday
about how especially sjw's left this
feel
feel totally entitled to just walk up to
people and hit him in the face we saw
that video of the this Yaniv character
assaulting a journalist who tried to ask
him a question well you bring dueling
back
not so much of a problem anymore that's
something I would like to see you know
this is what we need our political
candidates to be talking about
one of them that seriously suggests we
should at least consider maybe ha form
some sort of exploratory committee to
consider the pros and cons that's all
I'm asking for
okay well um moving on there's a there's
a new art exhibit that you can go check
out if you want just open in New York
it's called abortion is normal that's
the name of the art exhibit and the
point of the art exhibit is to send a
message that well abortion is normal and
here's a little propaganda piece that
speaking of Bloomberg this is a
propaganda piece that Bloomberg News put
together for it
[Music]
the reason this show is important aside
from I guess the obvious which is
America's ability to fight and ensure
that our reproductive rights are
maintained it's important because we're
trying to make a statement that these
words are not just a woman's there's
this woman's issues but a nation
motivates everyone we're in a time where
although a lot of progress has been made
until the progress stops at a point
where everyone actually has an equal
reproductive rights to choose whatever
they would like to do with their own
body we need to continue to buy it
[Music]
in the light
alright first of all
can we go back to the first second
of this video just freeze-frame it right
there okay so you're doing normal wrong
this is that's not normal the feminists
the problem with them is
they have no idea what normal is so they
want to call things normal they don't
know what that means
they say abortion is normal and the
first image they show us is one of a
large naked woman in a weird with in a
weird mask squatting on a stool and
leering at the camera that's not you
know it when I think normal that's not
where my mind goes
I would call that image many things
normal probably is not on the list
besides which why do they need abortion
to be normal
what's what's the point of that
it's like the left can't decide if
normal is good or bad they they kind of
wave her back and forth on this one
minute they're justifying something on
the basis that it's normal in the next
minute they're tearing things down on
the basis that they're too normal
so for example could I argue what would
any leftist find it persuasive if I
argued for traditional gender roles on
the basis that it's normal and many
societies have had them going back
thousands of years would that work for a
leftist of course not no but killing
your baby is okay because lots of people
have done it for thousands of years
here's I I think here's a general rule
that holds true most of the time and
that is this if you have to go around
insisting that something is normal
you know that's a pretty good indication
that it isn't
that's sort of the whole whole point of
a normal thing is that you don't have to
tell people it's normal so I wouldn't
need to start a campaign or have an art
exhibit called blue jeans are normal
where I'm insisting that it's normal for
people to wear blue jeans because
everybody knows it's normal because
everybody wears them and so you don't
need to tell people
besides that like I said it's it's
irrelevant because normal doesn't mean
good
is abortion normal it I mean in a sense
yeah it is in in the sense that you've
got you know hundreds of thousands of
babies are killed every year 60 million
have been killed in this in this country
since roe v-- wade so it is kind of a
normal thing and since that it happens
regularly across the world you've got
you know fifty million abortions every
single year fifty million
and yes you go back thousands of years
there have been societies barbaric
societies that have murdered their
children
so if by normal we just mean lots of
people do it then yes abortion is normal
quote unquote but also by that
definition then lots of other bad things
are normal
lying is normal even for women as we've
covered stealing is normal
murder is normal gossip is normal
gluttony is normal envious on all of the
seven deadly sins are normal
all of these things are normal but that
doesn't make them good or right or or
preferable obviously
but this is the kind of sort of grasping
at straws that you see the supporters of
abortion do because they can't it's very
difficult for them to present an
argument that abortion is actually a
good thing or actually morally
acceptable
so there
grasping for other things and in this
case they're saying it's normal
yeah who cares
that is not the point at all in fact I
would say
yes it's normal that's the problem
it's it's a problem that it's normal in
this society for us to to look at
children as cancers or inconveniences
as obstacles in the way of our greater
fulfillment
and it's a problem that a normal
solution for that issue is to kill them
that's a problem
all right well get the emails in a
second but first if you're not already a
subscriber you're really missing out and
right now using promo code Walsh you'll
get 10% off any plan that you choose
head over to daily wire comm / subscribe
and pick the plan that's right for you
for as little as 10 bucks a month
members get our all of our articles add
free access to all of our live shows the
full show library 3 hours of Ben Shapiro
every day
select bonus content access to the
mailbag much more than that even plus
our new all-access to gives you live
online Q&A discussions with me Ben
Shapiro Andrew clave and Michael Knowles
plus all of our daily wire writers and
special guests and don't forget you also
get the greatest of all beverage vessels
the glorious beautiful wonderful
iconic legendary leftist here's tumblr
all right we'll go to emails Matt Walsh
Oh at gmail.com
this is from Lin says hello Matt I was
wondering if you happen to see this
statement from somebody on your favorite
site Twitter it is my favorite site I
hate to say and then she provides a link
from somebody named Morgan Jerkins and
apparently a best-selling author and she
says well that's what she says about
herself in the bio anyway and the tweet
says
writers do not date or invest any
significant amount of energy into a
person who does not read your work
that's Morgan Jerkins now back to Lynn
says I've often wondered if your wife
listens to your show slash reads your
work if so how does that affect what you
say and write if at all if not do you
agree with the tweeter that this is a
problem
um Yellen first of all I have I did see
that that thing that somebody tweeted
I disagree with the tweeter as you call
her
I totally dead-ass disagree I mean that
sounds like excellent advice for anyone
who wants to be alone and miserable
forever
because if your litmus test for a
potential mate is that they have to be a
fan of yours well that's just called
narcissism that is called pathological
narcissists narcissism and also
insecurity and it is not a recipe for
relational success but put a mildly um
my wife since since you asked does
listen to my podcast sometimes she does
read some of my stuff
she's not the most loyal listener or
reader that I have and and that's
perfectly fine
it's more than fine actually I think I'd
be kind of uncomfortable if my wife was
a huge fan I mean if I was like her
favorite writer and her favorite podcast
actually favorite
I'd be uncomfortable you know I like for
her to have interests outside of me
personally
now when I say that your spouse
shouldn't be your fan I mean that in a
certain sense in another sense if by fan
we just mean supporter and courage or
somebody rooting for you then yeah
obviously your you should be a fan of
your spouse and your spouse should be
your fan in that sense
but not the not-not fan in the sense of
like somebody who asks for your
autograph okay so I'm talking about that
sense of fan and in that sense no I
wouldn't want my spouse to be that
that's weird
and by the way writers aren't special
just one way to make a living
so if the spouse of a writer has to read
everything that they write then it
stands to reason that the spouse of a
plumber asked to take a real interest in
plumbing and the spouse of a mechanic
has to love cars etc but obviously it's
perfectly fine if you're a mechanic and
your wife knows nothing about cars and
doesn't care it's fine just like it's a
perfectly fine if you're a writer and
your spouse isn't a big reader and maybe
isn't really interested in the stuff
that you write
who cares I think um I think what's
important is is respect
and if I want to be gracious and
generous to the person who wrote this
this tweet I would say maybe that's what
she was going for and she just
communicated it
awkwardly
as a best-selling writer according to
her she should be able to communicate
better than that through the written
word but maybe that's what she was going
for I we talked about respect okay so
it's crucial that your spouse respect
what you do if if my wife had no respect
for my work well that would be hard to
handle
I don't need her love all of it I don't
need her to read all of it
in general I do need her to have respect
for what I do just like she needs me to
have respect for what she does
and if you don't have that in a marriage
and there are you know that's there are
marriages where that's the case where
there's no respect between spouses and
that's obviously deadly for you
it can't survive very long
circumstance like that okay this is from
Dolph says oh great bearded one dead ass
is New York City slang for serious or
real or not joking examples I'm dead-ass
equals I'm serious
I'm I could just say I'm dead-ass
okay also another example he dead-ass
ate that whole cake equals he really ate
that whole cake
it can also be applied as a question but
the context as a question implies if
it's a threat or if you're dead ass
asking if they're dead ass
I'm confused
okay so he says if you and I are having
a conversation and you tell me your kid
broke a window I'll use dead-ass to ask
if you're a hundred percent serious
about this however if you step on
somebody and the response is them asking
if you're dead ass or just a simple dead
ass
this has now escalated to the threat of
a fight
hope this helps you understand
Jeremy or a dolphin
I I don't need help understanding I get
it okay
look fam
lit bro okay I dead asked I get it I'm
um
you know I'm the coolest dad on this
block or a reason main reason being I'm
the only dad on the block because we
live in the middle of nowhere but still
but my kids are teenagers they're gonna
look they're gonna be raising the roof
as the kids say how cool their dad is
they're gonna know their dad is the is
the bomb
ba-bam
um and this is from Jeremy says I'm the
classic longtime listener first-time a
mailer and wanted to ask you for some
personal advice I wanted to know whether
I should delete Twitter keep my cartoon
avatar account or change the account to
my real name
I must preface that I live in Canada and
that's the biggest reason I ended up
creating a cartoon avatar account I do
fear the potential social and government
reaction to my thoughts as I know
recently I was banned temporarily for
stating that there are two genders or
even putting out tweets questioning the
bias of the RCMP when they put up
rainbow flags and emblems in place of
the normal Canadian flag which also got
me banned temporarily personally I'm
leaning towards deleting my account
however I have a sort of love-hate
relationship where I do like being able
to vent sometimes about the insanity
from the left rather than going to my
friends or family I greatly admire your
thoughts and feel free to reach out to
me anytime thank you for very much for
your time well Jeremy I am you know and
I'm dead-ass serious about this I guess
I don't need to add okay that's
redundant so I'm serious serious about
this
I would say delete your account
if those are the options at your Wang
then I would say just delete it and
honestly it's got nothing to do with
your being afraid of backlash or
reprisals or anything I think if you're
if you're posting anonymously you're
probably pretty safe from that but I
think just in general social media is an
enormous waste of time
think it's it's eating our souls and our
lives
and if you can escape it then I would
definitely say escape
and I say that as someone who makes a
living on the Internet and on social
media
and you know III give this advice to
people all the time if everybody took my
advice and stopped going on the internet
and stopped using social media or at
least cut way way way back that would
destroy my livelihood and I'd have to go
and get a real job I don't want to have
to do that but I'm still I still just
have to be honest with you so selfishly
I want you to stay on Twitter and I want
you to stay you know use the internet as
much as possible that's my selfish
feeling but in reality if I'm being
honest I think it'd probably be better
for you and for everybody if you didn't
I'll tell you the honest truth of it
okay and I know you could say it's easy
for me to say this and and it is but it
really is true that if I if I didn't
have to be online for my job I wouldn't
be I would I wouldn't be on Twitter if I
didn't have to be there I wouldn't be on
Facebook I'm not gonna say I would never
use the internet but I would use its
parent
and part of the way that I know that is
that when I go on vacation or something
or I have off for a few days
well I don't have to pay attention at
all I don't I generally don't use the
internet at all I don't use social media
and I don't miss it I have no compulsion
to use it
you know if I could take off for two
weeks which I rarely am able to but if I
do I really have no desire to pick it up
and go on social media when I'm in the
thick of it you know on it on a regular
day it I do feel the compulsion
but if I can put it down for a minute
and just separate myself from it then
that compulsion goes away very quickly
so it's a it there is an addiction there
but it's a very weird kind of addiction
and that it's really intense when you're
in the midst of it but it's also really
easy to break
I think it's probably true for anyone if
you were to just if you were to here's
what here's my here's my suggestion for
you Jeremy
um
what I would suggest is try this just
trial basis
don't go on social media for a week just
a week
and see how you feel I'm betting I'd put
a lot of money on this that after a week
you have no desire to get on because
you'll you'll discover that you're
happier without it it wasn't making your
life any better
find other things to do with your time
and you'll probably have very little
desire to pick it up and go on it again
so just just give it a shot
that's what I would say
and I think
we will yes wrap it up there
thank somebody for watching and thanks
for listening Godspeed the Matt Walsh
show is produced by Sean Hampton
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there